okay so in Attack on Titan there have
been over 150 different alien Kings and
in this video we're about to explain
which ones were completely useless and
which ones actually did a decent job the
most important factor in doing this
ranking is whether the king's actions
had a mostly positive or negative impact
on the people but along the way we'll
also take into account other factors
like their mental stability and how well
they reacted in a crisis alright
starting off in last place the worst
King in history is the man who was
single-handedly responsible for getting
aliens thrown into internment zones the
name of that man was Carl Fritz although
he later changed his name to Carl rice
and to explain his weird Life Choices we
need to examine his backstory in the
centuries before Carl was born the alien
Empire had been using Titans to brutally
take over mankind wiping out entire
civilizations in the process and
forcefully spreading the blood of yamir
from country to Country according to
Willy Tiber the total number of people
that were killed by the aldenian empire
was more than triple the current global
population meaning by default eldia
wiped out even more people than were
killed by the rumbling when it comes to
Carl he was understandably ashamed by
that history and he clearly felt like he
had to do something about it as Prince
of the Empire he knew that he'd
eventually become king and gain all the
power that comes with that and once it
actually happened he went on to do more
damage to aliens than anyone else in
history a quick example of what I mean
is how in the past having emir's blood
used to be a status symbol but by the
time Carl's running was over subject of
Emir were rounded up segregated from
society and treated like animals for the
next 100 years what makes it worse is
that all the suffering we've seen wasn't
some kind of accident it was a thing
that Carl knew was going to happen as a
consequence of his deal with the Tiber
family now the way I see it him wanting
to make up for 2 000 years of mass
murder that was a good thing but the way
he went about solving it was probably
the dumbest thing anyone could have done
Carl's problem was that he thought the
Empire had done so much wrong that
nothing could ever make up for it
causing him to just abandon everything
to create a brand new Society on parody
by making this one decision he spit
apart the royal family leaving behind
all members who disagreed with him and
condemning aldians around the planet to
a lifetime of subjugation for aldians on
the island their situation wasn't even
that much better as Carl used the
founder to alter their memories so that
they forgot all knowledge of the outside
of course there were certain people like
armin's great-great-grandparents who
held on to physical evidence that
couldn't be a race but to fix this Carl
made it so that all these kind of
materials were illegal and the MPS were
responsible for destroying it and also
for suppressing any theories about life
outside the walls from Carl's point of
view all of this was necessary to
maintain peace on the island but in his
own words he said that if Mali were to
get stronger in the future he'd accept
it if they exterminated his new Society
whichever way you look at it those
aren't the words of a king who actually
cares about his people and his dark side
was proven even further when he ordered
the execution of the ackermann in Asian
Bloodlines because ackermans and Asians
are immune to the Founder's mind control
Carl saw them as a threat to the
temporary piece he was trying to create
and so he virtually destroyed them all
to prevent other people from learning
the truth as if that wasn't bad enough
Fritz then changed his last name to rice
in an effort to protect himself with the
fritz name being passed to a random
aldian family who had none of yumir's
blood this meant the races could control
the island in secret and have a more
comfortable existence since no one in
the general Republic would think that
they were in charge finally to guarantee
that his dumb decisions couldn't be
reversed by his descendants King rice
made his Infamous vow to announce War
this vow essentially removed the Free
Will of every Royal budded founding
Titan who would come after him and it
guaranteed that his ideology would live
on as long as a member of the rise
family possessed the coordinate the fact
he had to make this foul kinda shows you
that on a subconscious level Carl must
have known that no reasonable person
would ever agree with his ideas unless
they were literally brainwashed now just
before we move on I want to thank
flexispot standing desk for sponsoring
today's video Standing desks are one of
the best things you can do for your back
if you're someone like me who just
instinctively crouches over whenever
we're sitting down ever since I began my
channel I always sat down like that
whenever I was editing videos for
literally hours on end but thanks to
flexispot I've been able to improve my
posture and productivity at the same
time for the last three months I've been
using the E8 desk which came with this
high quality bamboo desktop and on top
of this thing I have have my audio
equipment camera desktop laptop
microphones and it still has zero
problems going up or down you can adjust
the height so easily with just the touch
of a finger meaning you can sit down
whenever you want to sit down or stand
up when you feel like you need to right
now flexi spot are doing their summer
sale where you can save up to 130 pounds
on various standing desks and if you're
interested then I'd recommend acting
quickly since the sale does end on the
31st of July make sure you click the
link in the description to see all the
deals they have on offer and thanks
again to flexi spot for sponsoring the
channel moving on to the second worst
King that title goes to Rod rise also
known as the guy who calls 20 of the LDN
population ran away while his family was
being murdered and came dangerously
close to eating his own people in the
year 845 Rod unexpectedly became king of
the walls after his kids were smushed by
gretchiega but interestingly he hid the
fact that they were dead Rod knew that
the rice family's real power came from
their possession of the founding Titan
and that without it it's possible that
no mobiles wouldn't recognize his
authority that's why following the
incident he pretended as if free was
still alive while taking over all of her
responsibilities as the new king one
year later his Royal government then
decided to Cull the population on the
island since there were a bunch of
refugees from wall Mario that they
didn't know what to do with according to
Pixis the men in charge wanted to reduce
the number of people they had to feed
and considering that Rod was the acting
King we have to assume that he had final
say on how they were going to do it in
the end the world government sent an
untrained Army of 250
000 people to reclaim umaria which by
this point was infested with Titans and
as you can imagine the true purpose of
this mission was for all of them to get
eaten now I'm sure there are certain
purple alien would argue that losing 20
of your population is Justified if it
means that there's more food for
everyone else but in this case there is
a reason why it's more messed up than
you think the manga confirmed that
before Mali attacked the war the
monarchy was actively encouraging people
to move into places is like shiganshana
the reason for this is that they wanted
there to be humans living in Frontline
towns so that times would be attracted
to those areas instead of trying to
breach the main wall despite that as
soon as shigans was actually breached it
only took the Royal government one year
to decide to abandon those same people
who they convinced to go there in the
first place we all know that there's no
circumstance where Rod rice would have
sent 250 000 people from the interior to
be eaten but when it came to the
refugees who had nothing it was easier
to have them killed rather than finding
an alternate solution after that Rod
continued to pretend as if everything
was fine and it wasn't until Aaron
revealed his powers in trust the rod was
forced to tell the truth about his
family with the knowledge that Aaron had
the founding Titan the Royal Government
tried on multiple occasions to get
custody of him before finally succeeding
in season three however being the coward
that he is what wanted the founder to
return to the royal family but he didn't
want to be the one who got titanized for
that reason he had the interior police
kidnap his secret love shot Historia who
he'd only met one time in his entire
life as Kenny said Rod never cared about
anything except protecting himself and
so turning his story Into the founder
was a way of guaranteeing his own power
while shortening the life of his last
remaining child not only does that make
him the second worst father on this list
but when she decided not to go along
with this plan he lost all composure in
a way that no real king should have done
throughout the night Rod's gigantic body
then crawled towards Orville district
and at that point in time he was a
genuine threat to all life on the island
the anime made it clear that Rod had the
potential to crash directly through the
wall and had he done that it would have
exposed the war Titans to sunlight it
was heavily implied in season 2 that if
sunlight touches the wall Tyson then
they'd be able to break free and so
bearing that in mind Rod nearly began a
chain reaction that could have led to a
mass extinction event Historia and the
other Scouts were the only ones who
prevented that from happening but had
they not been there there's a
possibility that Rod rice could have
accident dentally began the rumbling
next in line we have the original Fritz
who is by far the most evil person in
this video and his long list of crimes
include forcing his own children to eat
their mother's corpse as the king of
eldia Fritz has a very mixed Legacy
depending on whether you were born in
aldian or whether you were forced to
join the aldians like Emir in the years
before she gained the power of the
Titans Fritz would send his men to burn
down villages imprison the survivors of
slaves and use their free labor to
benefit the tribe in various ways these
unlucky people had their tongues removed
to stop them from talking back and they
all lived in constant fear of what else
might be done to them that's why to
ensure their own Survival the slaves
just did whatever they were told and
this Behavior was so ingrained that
yamir kept obeying Fritz even after
becoming the most powerful thing on the
planet therefore it's clear that for all
the non-aliens who were living inside
the Empire Fritz was by far the worst
thing that ever happened and it
shouldn't come as a surprise that they
tried to assassinate him for many ethnic
though his obsession with expanding the
empire did lead to an improvement in
their standard of living but due to him
being a raging psycho who was clearly
lacking something mentally it didn't
feel right ranking for its any higher
than this switching over to his
descendant Frida rice she comes in at
seventh place on the list and has The
Unwanted record of being the first Royal
to lose the founding Titan prior to
becoming Queen Frida's main ambition was
to free Humanity from the Titans outside
the walls and had she followed through
with that plan she would have obviously
ranked way higher in this video
unfortunately after inheriting the
founder her mind was overtaken by the
first Rice King meaning she was helpless
to do anything when the Warriors burst
through wallmaria up until that
particular day freda's time his Queen
didn't seem to have any major incidents
and a large part of her Reign was just
spent giving religious speeches to VIPs
inside the wars beyond that she was also
the only member of the royal family to
acknowledge her sister's existence and
while that might make her a great person
as a queen she only had one defining
moment in the rice Chapel when Frida was
confronted by Grisha you could tell that
she kind of sympathized with his
perspective but her will wasn't strong
enough to overcome Carl's ideology
because of that she was happy to accept
if Marley exterminated all life of the
island which is something that Aaron and
gretcher took incredibly personally
ultimately Frida ranks lowly in this
video because of how badly she failed to
protect anyone during one of the worst
days in Eldon history and for how easily
she was beaten despite having the
founding Titan anyhow flashing back two
thousand years after King Fritz died he
was replaced by his daughter's Maria
rosencina and although we can assume
that they weren't as crazy as him the
fact remains that they did still do
exactly what he wanted with his dying
breath the Old King told them to have as
many descendants as possible so that
yamir's blood would never die out and by
them fulfilling that request it meant
the Titans continued to multiply if they
ignored his request then it would have
literally saved billions of lives down
the road but for some reason reason they
chose to follow the king's instructions
even after he was gone my personal
theory on this is that if we think about
it when Mario Rosen Cena were growing up
all they saw throughout their whole
childhood was their dad always getting
what he wanted as an example anytime he
told Emir to do something she would do
that thing even though she was like
significantly more powerful than him and
of course no one else would have been
brave enough to tell him no besides the
people that tried to kill him in that
sense the three girls had never known a
life that didn't involve everyone doing
what their father said and so when he
told them to keep expanding his Thailand
Empire my guess is that they never even
considered that disobeying him was an
option because of that it's not totally
their fault that They carried on his
legacy of global domination hence why
they do rank slightly ahead of him now
before we move on to the kings and
queens who actually did something good
there's two more people that we need to
quickly explain the first is the puppet
King Fritz who was described by Pixis as
a symbol of human prosperity and was
apparently well liked by the population
I as we established earlier in the video
this Fritz never actually belongs to the
Royal bloodline but instead he's from a
line of aldians who never became
subjects of yumeir back in ancient times
the eldian tribe used to just be regular
humans just like everyone else and it
was only the descendants of yamir that
could be transformed into Titans over
time their numbers increased until they
became the majority of the elding
population but there were still some
minority Bloodlines who stayed humid and
therefore couldn't be mind controlled by
the founding Titan the puppet King Fritz
belongs to one of those noble families
and based on his age we can assume that
he was on the throne for at least 40 or
50 years in the first episode of season
3 we found out from Sasha that once a
year the fake King donates extra food
rations to the people this yearly
tradition was likely a calculated move
from the rice family in order to keep
the people happy and make sure there's
no uprisings and in the year 850 Rod
rice increased the amount of food being
donated for this exact reason during
that meeting the Papa King Fritz sat
there without saying a word and that's
because as a nearly senile old man he
rarely takes part in decision making and
had a hard time paying attention even
when his own government was being
overthrown as a result it's hard to say
for sure if his actions ever had a
positive or negative impact on society
but at the very least pixus believed
that his existence was a good thing for
public morale following that we have
historius unnamed grandfather who was
possessed by the will of Carl Fritz but
luckily for this guy he never got tested
in the same way that Historia or Frida
were as far as we saw the biggest
challenge he faced came from his two
sons who were constantly trying to
persuade him to eradicate the Titans
gradually they annoyed him so much that
he locked up a young Rod rice in a
dungeon demonstrating his full
commitment to Carl's philosophy another
thing that happened during his Reign was
Irvin's father being executed for his
theory about there being humans outside
the walls and this was yet another
example of MP's murdering civilians to
maintain the lies of the first king
compared to other kings on this list
though his story is Grandfather's record
as a king couldn't have been as bad as
other people on this list since as far
as we know he never had to deal with a
real crisis and so because of that he
comes in at fifth place okay so in
fourth place we have URI rice also known
as historia's long-lost uncle and out of
all the kings who were possessed by Carl
Fritz URI was the only one to make some
kind of positive change during his Reign
the monarchy officially ended their
persecution of the ackermans which had
been going on for nearly a hundred years
for Generations ackermans had been
systematically hunted down until there
were only two branches of the family
left one that lived in the underground
and another that lived near Chicago of
course this extermination is exactly
what caltrus wanted for the reasons I
mentioned earlier but when it came to
URI he accepted that it should never
have happened and from that moment
onwards the surviving ackermans were no
longer enemies of the royal family URI
also reacted super calmly in her crisis
situation definitely way better than his
brother did and so everything considered
he deserves a place near the top of the
list moving on to the third best alien
king this one goes to Willy Tiber and
before you say anything yes I know he
doesn't have Royal Blood but there is a
good political reason why he has to be
on this list a hundred years ago when
Carl Fritz fled to the island he left
behind thousands of aliens who stayed on
the Malian continent and those people
were under the control of the type of
family in the same way that the rice is
the kings of the war secretly running
things from the Shadows the tibers were
essentially Kings outside the walls who
were pulling the strings in Mali judging
from appearances they even look like
royalty I mean they have the Royal
Guards you know Titan that belongs to
them and according to Poco they lived in
massive Mansions so from that
perspective they were royalty in
everything but name however just like
Carl Fritz the type is basically allowed
Marley to do whatever it wanted to the
Aldean population and it was only in
this new generation with Willie and his
sister that they were able to make
active steps to improve the lives of the
people that Fritz Left Behind for
instance Willie understood that if
technology surpasses the power of the
Titans then both Mali and the aliens
inside Marley would one day get wiped
out because of that he worked hard to
improve the perception of eldians by
forming personal relationships with
influential politicians his long-term
aim was to convince these VIPs that
aliens who live outside the walls can
co-exist with Humanity as we saw from
his conversation with mcgath he wanted
people to sympathize with the aldians
inside the internment zones and to
accomplish that mission he was fully
willing to sacrifice his own life that
level of self-sacrifice is a trait that
you'd never expect to see from someone
in such a privileged position and really
hoped that his death could unite
everyone together against a common enemy
while improving the global reputation of
aliens obviously you can still criticize
him for knowingly putting people in
danger but had his plan worked the way
he wanted those sacrifices could have
led to World Peace based on that Willy's
actions as the head of the Tiber family
were Justified to save the aldian race
living outside the walls but in the end
he was still overshadowed by the next
person on this list coming in at the
number two spot we have Historia who
easily has the most impressive record of
any ruler on parody which includes
revealing the truth about the outside
world overseeing the development of new
technology putting her life on the line
to inherit the Beast Titan and other
things that directly benefited the
island in order to tell the full story
of why she deserves such a high ranking
the first thing we need to do is
Flashback to win the military overthrew
the world government we saw in chapter
62 that a lot of the general public
wasn't happy about the news that King
Fritz was removed with one journalist
doubting if his replacement could win
over the population this feeling is
something the Historia was aware of as
she suspected that people wouldn't
accept a random girl they never heard of
just taking the throne to fix the
problem she wanted to try and earn their
respect for herself hence why the future
Queen put herself on the front line
against her dad's enormous Titan by
being the one to deal the finishing blow
to Rod rice Historia not only saved the
island from literally the biggest Titan
they ever face but in the process she
made herself a unifying figure who
everyone could support this Unity helped
to calm down the political chaos inside
the walls and avoid a civil war with the
Nobles which could have happened if they
didn't accept her as Queen according to
Aaron the support for Historia grew even
stronger in the months after her
coronation when she used the money taken
from corrupt politicians to create a
brand new orphanage for deprived
children by yourself this gesture proved
that she cares about the lower classes
and the fact she had to argue with the
Nobles to get it done only made her even
more popular however this does bring us
to one of the downsides of historius
time as Queen which is that she had a
lot less political strength than her
predecessors for example in previous
generations the Monarch could pretty
much do anything they wanted even if
their ideas were sadistic or just plain
stupid but when Historia took over that
wasn't the case naturally she did still
have some power like when she made the
final decision to reveal the truth about
the world but what's clear is that on a
day-to-day basis she wasn't the one
running the country in reality it was
Zachary Pixis and Irvin who were
controlling things in in the beginning
with Armin describing the monarchy as
being mainly just for show in spite of
that historia's actions as Queen were
still important to the survival of
everyone inside the walls and it's a
fact that Humanity was only able to
progress once she replaced the previous
world government during this era new
technologies would developed such as the
Thunder Spears and the Executioner from
hell and the general population was
supplied with Limitless energy in the
form of glowing stones that were found
in the rice Chapel other improvements
include retaking wolmaria from the
Titans not to mention she was the first
queen or King in a century to form a
relationship with a foreign Nation on
that topic it was thanks to their
relationship with his Rue that Historia
was presented with a 50-year plan to
defend the island which involved gaining
the ability to do the rumbling on a
personal level that was bad news for
Historia because as the only person of
Royal Blood she would need to inherit a
Titan shifter and then give birth to a
bunch of children who would need to eat
her at some point in the future even
though Aaron and everyone else was
horrified at the thought of her doing
this she was the one who stayed composed
and volunteered to inherit the Beast
Titan from her perspective it was the
people of the island who mattered more
than anything else which is why later on
she kept Aaron's secret about his plan
to do the rumbling even though morally
she didn't think it was the right thing
to do
finally as we now move on to the best
alien king in history it's worth
remembering that two important factors
in this ranking were whether the Monarch
had a positive impact on aldians and
whether they reacted well in a crisis
bearing that in mind I thought it made
sense that the number one king is
someone who not only solved the
worldwide crisis but in the process
saved every single subject of Emir
although we don't actually know this
King's first name he was mentioned in
chapter 114 by Tom Sava who'd been
searching through the Beast Titans
memories those memories showed him that
600 years ago there was a disease that
swept across the planet and caused a
massive decrease in both the human and
ldm population one day however the King
used his founding Titan to redesign the
bodies of every subject of Emir in a way
that made them completely immune what
makes this even more impressive is that
unlike the selfish Nobles who existed in
the present day the king wanted to use
his power to help all of his subjects
regardless of who they were this is in
contrast to someone like Carl Fritz who
would have just let the disease ripped
through the Empire and it's also
different to someone like Rod rice who
couldn't care less about the lives of
peasants by doing what he did the
unnamed King proved himself to be
compassionate towards all of his people
and since we don't know much else about
him his legacy is defined by that one
action personally I do think it's enough
to deserve the number one spot but let
me know in the comments down below if
you agree or disagree and if you do
disagree then let me know who would you
put is number one and who would you put
in last place anyhow thanks for watching
as always and I'd appreciate it if you
dropped a like if you haven't already
and until the next one peace out